foreign
[Music]
movie gxk the new Empire the red Kong
also referred to as orangegong is
speculated to be even larger than both
Godzilla and Kong based on the teaser it
is shown perched on the throne
surrounded by the skulls of numerous
Titans including Godzillas and Kongs
while the exact size of the redcon is
uncertain it is expected to be a massive
creature significantly larger than any
smaller titles like the skull crawlers
or Mothra to evoke a sense of awe and
fear in the viewers it would need to be
over 400 feet or 120 meters tall at the
minimum there is one theory that
suggests the red Kong may have been the
reason behind the ancient war between
the Godzillas and the gong species and
also that it may be a solo Titan Hunter
but since the next movie would have a
bunch of talents in London scenes I
suspect that the retcon would use some
Sinister way to recruit other Titans to
form a coalition to battle both the Big
G and Kong
first we would need to establish one
important thing as to why it would need
allies or minions in the upcoming battle
against these two Apex Titans well we
need to assess his enemies here it might
just not be the Apex Titans it might be
other titles too the ones that bowed
down to the alpha the beaters that might
assess either Kong or Godzilla in a
fight as we saw in GVK two talents
working together is a possibility we
also saw that Godzilla helping out
titanus nakika and Behemoth on two
different instances as well as
humiliating and subordinating Tiamat
amhuluk and Silla so these are titles
that either might hold a grudge or be
compelled to assess the G-Man in the
future we also saw Kong helping out
smaller creatures of Skull Island and
also defeat camazods and skull crawlers
at two different times so even Kong
would have maybe allies but definitely
he would have enemies
for the redcon to defeat either or both
of these two Titans it would have to
know the strengths and the weaknesses of
both these super species Godzilla is a
400 feet or 120 meters tall reptilian
title with the power of the splitting
atom inside his body he weighs more than
a hundred thousand tons he is able to
take a hell of a beating and has a
ton of stamina he can shoot the atomic
breath from his mouth and can go feral
and tear the red monkey a new hole to
poop from and in the most desperate
moments he can go Kaboom thermonuclear
come on the other hand has the agility
he has the cunning and a tactical mind
for a battle he has a lot of experience
and also the acts which he can either
use to cut and sell Maya squid sushi in
the hollow Earth market or use it for
war and to defeat even the greatest of
enemies if he could defeat War bats with
his bare hands imagine him with the ax
so to counter both of them he would need
I mean the red Kong he would need more
than just his balls he would need an
entire army or at the very least couple
of minions
as for now we don't really know the
strength and weaknesses of the red Kong
but he could provoke Godzilla by
employing hit and run tactics from a
distance with him appearing similar to
Kong or at least from a far away
distance so this would lead Godzilla to
seek revenge and break the truth
similarly the red car might use its
special abilities possibly indicated by
its glowing eyes to trick Kong into
thinking that Godzilla has attacked him
or those he cares about with his Atomic
breath this deception could fuel another
clash between the two Titans while the
red gong waits for the opportune moment
to strike he could do so by sending
forth Godzilla enemies first and Hulu
who no doubt holds a grudge against
G-Man by interfering with his near
victory over Behemoth jantimat who wants
a layer bag the one forcefully taken by
Godzilla in dominion and of course the
mutors to lessen Godzilla's attacking
Power by their EMP dampening abilities
as well as their desire to feed off of
the radiation from the Big G
being the evil villain that we are
hoping him to be he might also have
Kong's enemies on his side for the epic
showdown the first of his Titan allies
that are actually Kong's Nemesis would
be gamazotz the flying bat Island that
was defeated by Kong and Skull Island
Alice in Kingdom called the storyline
its death was never really shown it was
only thrown back into the hollow Earth
and ended with a vengeful shriek it
would be so cool to see a flying bat
creature in live action against a giant
ape and on the ground it would be the
skull Devils the hyper carnivorous ever
starving calm killers they both either
have enmity towards The Big Ape or they
are just naturally driven to attack the
Kong species but there is also a
possibility that the red car might be
viewed also as an enemy by them as well
I'm just laying out the probabilities so
yeah this is just speculation but we
might have three Titans
and the murals maybe even Siller against
Godzilla and cameras that's the war bats
and the cranium reptons against gong
with the evil red Kong on the side light
lines waiting for the opportune moment
to place the killing strike no doubt
this will be a movie that will have both
the Beloved icons fighting side by side
against the Undiscovered threats as well
as other well-known threats but they
might not be in it alone as an apex
Titan we have never really seen Godzilla
calling the other Titans to war the way
Ghidorah did and they all obeyed while
there are instances and moments where we
send them back to their hibernation
places made them obey his power or
restore the balance between war and
super species there was never really a
call to Arms kind of thing and surely if
there was I would pee my pants with
pride and honor imagine the G-Man giving
an alpha call and slowly on the horizon
first as Silhouettes then with close-up
shots you see the Allied Titans hitting
the goal Behemoth Methuselah and also
the queen Muto coming to teach the other
mutos a lesson in humility and in the
air Rodan side by side with the newly
morphed Mothra this scene here would
beat endgame's final battle entrance
it'll be that but on a bigger proportion
with monsters
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates and new
videos here on this channel take care
fam